Speaker 1: All right, this next topic, I've
really been hesitating to do it because it's
completely speculative, but sometimes it becomes
so hard to explain behavior in empirical ways
with facts that we have that it becomes difficult
to avoid speculating.
So I'm going to say this super clearly, this
is speculative thinking out loud based on
the number of people who have written to me,
you guys and said, Could Vladimir Putin be
terminally ill?
And could that explain his behavior, which
is unhinged and seemingly reckless, as well
as potentially self-destructive to himself
and to Russia?
Vladimir Putin seems to be making decisions
that apparently can't end well for him, nor
for Russia.
The economic damage being inflicted on Russia
as a result of the sanctions in response to
Putin's aggression, according to some, could
damage Russia economically for decades.
And what many of you are thinking from the
emails I'm getting is could some horrible
illness explain it?
One person wrote to me and said Putin's face
is pudgy.
Could he be on steroids for some medical condition?
Could that be one reason for his rambling
and his increased aggression?
It's very vague.
It's very speculative.
Another post on the subreddit The David Pakman
Show subreddit said, Is Putin terminally ill?
And that's why consequences don't matter to
him.
Speculative Another aspect to this is the
pictures of Putin sitting cartoonishly far
away from people during recent meetings.
Yesterday, I retweeted an image from the morning
of Putin meeting with his supposedly top advisers,
and he quite literally appears to be at a
50 foot long table, 50 feet away from his
closest advisors.
And there's many possible explanations for
that.
He's generally known to be a germaphobe.
It could be that simple.
We heard.
While he's just very careful about COVID,
it could be, as we talked about on yesterday's
bonus show.
Putin may fear that someone within his advisors
might try to kill him, and so he's keeping
physical distance.
I mean, it really could be anything.
The other aspect of this that people have
talked about is that in two videos from last
week, videos which in principle were filmed
days apart, Vladimir Putin is wearing the
exact same suit and tie.
He seems disheveled.
He seemed sort of confused, leading to speculation
that the videos were filmed at the same time,
and Putin's not really well enough to be out
and filming videos regularly again.
It is completely speculative, and what's going
on here is we're all trying to come up with
explanations for unexplainable behavior from
Vladimir Putin.
Is he simply this much of an unhinged authoritarian
and he's not sick and he's just doing this
anyway?
Does he have a death wish?
Is he such a narcissist that he thinks he
won't end up hurt no matter what he does?
Or, you know, at the tail end of that is,
is he terminally ill and just trying to go
out with a bang?
No one hypothesis is that much crazier, that
much more crazier, that much more likely.
One journalist, Udo Lipsky's, who's the former
director of the German broadcaster ARD Studios
in Moscow, also brought up the possibility
that Putin could be suffering from a serious
health issue, said after seeing these recent
videos of Putin, he just doesn't look at all
like he looked months ago.
And Lipsky's highlighted claims by foreign
affairs specialists and academic Fiona Hill,
who said Putin could potentially be ill.
So that's the whole story.
You all now know everything I know and everything
that's been said.
I'm curious to hear your thoughts understanding
that this is not a news report of Putin being
sick.
This is, could this be going on?
Many of you seem to think it is, and you've
brought it to me.
And now you basically know all of the claims
that I'm aware of.
Let me know.
Find me on Twitter at De Packman.
I'm curious to hear your thoughts.
I am so thrilled that the audio podcast continues
to grow the audio podcast, even though we
are not necessarily in a time where interest
in political media is the highest you would
expect, although we are getting closer to
a midterm.
Our audio podcast is growing and growing and
growing, and I want to welcome everybody listening
who listens daily to the one hour audio podcast,
of course, available for free.
We are a viewer and listener supported program,
and I would love for you to sign up on our
website.
Join Packman dot com.
You do get a commercial free version of that
podcast or a video version if you prefer,
as well as access to our daily bonus show
as a member.
You can sign up at join Packman dot com.